THANK YOU.
>> YOU BET.
>> Carley: THANKS SO MUCH MARTHA
>> NOW LET'S TURN TO THIS.
FAR LEFT SQUAD MEMBER ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ WEIGHING IN ON HER
FUTURE, HER POLITICAL FUTURE AND
PRESIDENTIAL AMBITIONS AS GQ'S
NEWEST COVER GIRL.
>> Brian: ANOTHER REASON TO GET
GQ I GUESS.
THE PROGRESSIVE CONGRESSWOMAN
CLAIMING SHE WON'T GO ON TO RUN
THE COUNTRY BECAUSE QUOTE MY
EXPERIENCE HERE HAS GIVEN ME A
FRONT ROW SEAT TO HAVE DEEPLY
AND UNCONSCIOUSLY AS WELL AS
CONSCIOUSLY SO MANY PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY HATE WOMEN.
SHE REALLY LOVES THIS, DOESN'T
IT?
>> Steve: THEN SHE BEE MOANED
HER JOB IN CONGRESS SAYING
IMAGINE WORKING A JOB AND YOUR
BOSSES DON'T LIKE YOU AND FOLKS
ON YOUR TEAM ARE SUSPICIOUS OF
YOU AND THEN THE COMPETING
COMPANY IS TRYING TO KILL YOU.
>> Carley: WHAT?
>> Steve: SO WE HAVE SET UP A
CONVERSATION FOR OUR BUDDY AT
8:00 P.M. EASTERN TIME TUCKER
CARLSON WHO JOINS US NOW.
TUCKER AOC HAS A LOT TO SAY
[LAUGHTER].
>> THEY'RE TRYING TO KILL ME.
THEY HATE ME.
THEY JUST DON'T LIKE WOMEN.
REALLY?
WHO HATES WOMEN?
I NEVER MET ANYONE WHO HATES
WOMEN.
>> NOT YET.
>> MOST MEN ACTUALLY REALLY LIKE
WOMEN AS FAR AS I KNOW.
BUT, LOOK, SHE'S VERY EASY TO
MAKE FUN OF, BUT I THINK THE KEY
THING TO REMEMBER IS THIS WORKS,
A.
B, SHE MEANS IT.
SHE'S SINCERE IN IT.
SHE'S SO WRAPPED UP IN HER OWN
NARRATIVE SHE REALLY BELIEVES
SHE IS A VICTIM.
AND, C, CLEARLY SHE THINKS SHE'S
GOING TO BE PRESIDENT.
SHE HAS A SENSE OF HER OWN
DESTINY.
AND I THINK IT WOULD BE A HUGE
MISTAKE TO UNDERESTIMATE SOMEONE
LIKE THIS.
I THINK SHE'S VERY TALENTED.
OBVIOUSLY I THINK SHE'S
LUDICROUS, WE MORNING HER
MERCILESSLY, WELL DESERVED,
SHE'S A FRAUD.
SHE'S NOT A POP LIFT OR
SUPPRESSED, OF COURSE NOT.
SHE'S A TOOL OF THE PEOPLE
ALREADY IN CHARGE.
BUT I ALSO THINK SHE HAS A
POLITICAL FUTURE AND
CONSERVATIVES WOULD BE UNWISE TO
DISMISS HER AS JUST A FAD, SHE'S
MORE THAN THAT.
AND I THINK SHE IS GOING TO RUN
FOR PRESIDENT AND I THINK AT
SOME POINT SHE HAS A PRETTY GOOD
SHOT OF WINNING.
SO I WOULDN'T BLOW HER OFF AS A
MINOR PHENOMENON.
>> Brian: SHE REALLY DOESN'T
HAVE MUCH OF A CONSTITUENCY
OUTSIDE QUEENS, I DON'T THINK
SHE'S EVER EVEN IN QUEENS AND
WHEN SHE TRIES TO ENDORSE A
CANDIDATE IT DOESN'T REALLY GO
TOO WELL.
>> NO, BUT SHE IS THE MASTER OF
SOCIAL MEDIA, AND SHE HAS THE
KIND OF APPEARANCE OF
TRANSPARENCY.
SHE DID THIS VERY FAMOUS VIDEO
OF HERSELF APPLYING MAKEUP AND I
DIDN'T GET IT AT FIRST AND OF
COURSE MADE FUN OF IT BECAUSE
IT'S JUST NARCISSISM ON PARADE,
AS IF WE'RE INTERESTED IN
WATCHING HER APPLY MAKEUP CAN
YOU IMAGINE ANYTHING MORE
TEDIOUS ABOUT THAT?
BUT THERE IS SOMETHING ABOUT
THAT THAT'S VERY COMPELLING.
AND, AGAIN, SHE BELIEVES THAT
SHE HAS A DESTINY.
THAT SHE IS, AT SOME POINT GOING
TO ASCEND TO HIGH OFFICE.
I'VE WATCHED A LOT OF THIS OVER
30 YEARS AND THE PEOPLE WHO WIND
UP WINNING ARE THE ONES WHO ARE
COMPLETELY CONVINCED, ON THE
MOST BASIC LEVEL, THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE IN CHARGE IN THE
END.
WHO REALLY, I HATE TO SAY IT,
WHO BELIEVE IN THEMSELVES.
SO AS ABSURD AS SHE IS I SEE HER
AND THINK THIS THIS PERSON
ACTUALLY HAS A SHOT AND THAT'S
TERRIFYING BECAUSE SHE'S A
RIDICULOUS MARCH SA SIFT WITH NO
RECORD OF ACHIEVING ANYTHING
ONLY DESTROYING THINGS.
IT'S BAD.
IT'S SCARY.
>> Carley: SO SHE TALKED ABOUT
HOW THIS COUNTRY HATES WOMEN.
I AGREE, I DON'T FEEL HATED AT
ALL.
>> YOU ARE LOVED.
>> Carley: I LOVE LIVING HERE AS
A MATTER OF FACT.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO HER BEING
PRESIDENT SHE ALSO SAID I LIVE
IN A COUNTRY THAT WOULD NEVER
LET THAT HAPPEN DESPITE THE FACT
THAT THE VICE-PRESIDENT IS A
FEMALE, IF WE'RE STILL DOING
GENDER.
AND SHE'S SUPPOSED TO BE A ROLE
MODEL AND AN INSPIRATION OF
YOUNG WOMEN SO IS THIS A SORT OF
MESSAGE YOU WOULD THINK SOMEBODY
WHO'S SUPPOSED TO INSPIRE THE
NEXT GENERATION WOULD DELIVER?
>> WELL, I MEAN, THE MESSAGE IS
VERY COMMON NOW, WHICH IS I'M
OPPRESSED, I'M A VICTIM, GIVE ME
POWER.
I MEAN, THIS IS A MEANS TO
POWER, OF COURSE, AND THAT'S WHY
YOU SEE IT EVERYWHERE.
AT ITS CORE IT'S A LIE.
I MEAN I BET IF YOU WERE TO
INTERVIEW THE WOMEN IN HER
OFFICE AND ASK THEM WHO TREATS
YOU BETTER, YOUR BOSS, WHO'S A
WOMAN, OR THE MEN YOU WORK FOR?
I MEAN, AND YOU SEE THIS IN
OFFICES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
I MEAN IF YOU'RE REALLY HONEST
ABOUT IT, MEN HATE WOMEN.
REALLY?
IT'S NOT MALE BOSSES WHO
MISTREAT FEMALE EMPLOYEES.
LET'S STOP LYING ABOUT IT.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THE TRUTH.
WOMEN ARE MUCH TOUGHER ON WOMEN
THAN MEN ARE IN THE WORKPLACE
WHICH IS TRUE.
SORRY YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO SAY
THAT THAT'S REAL.
SO THE IDEA THAT SHE'S LIKE AN
ADVOCATE FOR WOMEN.
REALLY?
IN WHAT WAY?
IT'S ABSURD.
>> SHE ALSO SAID SHE COULD NEVER
MARRY A WHITE GUY SHE SHOULD
TELL HER WHITE BOYFRIEND THAT.
>> SHE IS WHITE.
THAT'S THE OTHER THING.
OH, I'M AN OPPRESSED RACIAL
MINORITY.
REALLY?
YOU'RE NAMED AFTER A
CONQUESTADOR.
YOU'RE FROM WEST CHESTER.
STOP IT.
AT HE TOO DUMB.
>> TUCKER YOU'RE UP EARLY TODAY
TALKING TO US, YOU'RE WORKING ON
FOX NATION, A BRAND NEW TWO-PART
SERIES AVAILABLE NOW ON FOX
NATION CALLED TRANSGRESS IVE THE
CONSULT OF CONFUSION.
YOU BROUGHT ALONG A PREVIEW CLIP
HOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO SET UP
WHAT WE'RE ABOUT TO SEE.
>> SO MANY OTHER THINGS WHAT'S
BEING SOLD AS A LIBERATION
MOVEMENT IS ACTUALLY CRUELTY AND
CRUELTY TO CHILDREN THAT SHOULD
BE ILLEGAL.
AND WE INTERVIEWED A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN THROUGH THE
SURGERIES WHICH ARE, YOU KNOW,
BASICALLY CASTRATION OR PHYSICAL
MUTILATION OF THE BODY, AND LOOK
BACK WITH HORROR AND REGRET.
AND THEIR VOICES SHOULD BE
HEARD.
THIS IS WRONG WHAT'S HAPPENING
IT SHOULD BE ILLEGAL AND I THINK
THIS DOCUMENTARY SHOWS IT.
>> Steve: ALL RIGHT.
LET'S ROLL THE CLIP.
WATCH THIS.
>> SO HISTORICALLY GENDER
DYSPHORIA AFFLICTED.01% OF THE
POPULATION SO ROUGHLY ONE IN
10,000 AND THEY WERE
OVERWHELMINGLY MALE.
THE NUMBERS WERE EVEN SMALLER
WHEN IT CAME TO FEMALES, I THINK
IT WAS ONE IN 30,000.
TODAY, THE NEWEST REPORT IS THAT
ONE IN 20 YOUNG WOMEN IN COLLEGE
ARE IDENTIFYING AS TRANS.
THAT IS AN ENORMOUS SPIKE.
IN THE UK WHERE THEY HAVE TRA
ICED MEDICAL CARE AND THEY CAN
SEE THE NUMBERS MORE EASILY,
THERE HAVE BEEN REPORTS OF A
4,000% SPIKE IN THE REFERRALS OF
THE YOUNG BIOLOGICAL WOMEN TO
THE NATIONAL GENDER SERVICE FOR
HORMONES FOLLOWED BY SURGICAL
INTERVENTION.
>> Steve: TUCKER, IN THAT LITTLE
CLIP RIGHT THERE, WHY ARE SO
MANY IDENTIFYING NOW AS TRANS?
>> WELL BECAUSE, OF COURSE,
THERE'S A LOT OF ENCOURAGEMENT
TO DO THAT I MEAN THIS IS BEING
SOLD ON SOCIAL MEDIA,
PARTICULARLY ON TIK TOK AND
INSTAGRAM AND THE REST, AS A WAY
OF PERSONAL LIBERATION AND IT'S
A LIE AND THE REST OF US HAVE
BEEN TOLD TO SHUT UP ABOUT IT
BECAUSE WE'RE BEING MEAN TO SOME
OPPRESSED COMMUNITY IF WE SAY
THIS.
OKAY.
YOU KNOW, MOST AMERICANS DON'T
CARE.
YOU WANT TO CALL YOURSELF
WHATEVER YOU WANT, YOU WANT TO
DRESS HOWEVER YOU WANT, MOST
PEOPLE DON'T CARE AND DON'T WANT
TO GET INVOLVED IN IT.
BUT IF THEY'RE SENDING CHILDREN
INTO IRREPARABLE SURGERIES AND
CASTRATING THEM AND STERILIZING
THEM FOR LIFE ANDR THEN WE HAVE
A MORALE OBLIGATION TO SAY, NO,
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO DO THAT,
THAT'S ILLEGAL.
WE HAVE TO BAN THIS.
IT'S ONE OF THE WORST THINGS
THAT'S HAPPENED IN OUR LIFE
TIMES AND THE REST HAS BEEN SO
INTIMIDATED BY THE SCREAMING OF
THE ACTIVISTS AND THE HIGHLY
FUNDED LOBBIES THEY HAVE IN
WASHINGTON WE'VE LET IT HAPPEN
AND REALLY HAVE BEEN COWED INTO
SILENCE.
YOU CAN'T DO THIS TO KIDS SORRY
NOT ALLOWED.
>> Brian: TWO-PART SERIES IS
AVAILABLE WHEN?
>> RIGHT NOW ON FOX NATION.
>> Brian: AT THIS MOMENT.
>> ALTHOUGH THIS MOMENT T
[LAUGHTER].
>> Carley: THANK YOU TUCKER.
THANK YOU FOR WAKING UP EARLY.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Brian: NOW YOU DON'T HAVE TO
GET GQ, WE GAVE YOU THE WHOLE
STORY.
>> I CANCELLED MY SUBSCRIPTION.
>> Brian: YOU MIGHT AS WELL EVEN
THOUGH THEY GIVE YOU COLOGNE IN
THE MIDDLE.
>> Steve: SIT IN THAT CHAIR
YOU'LL BE ON TV IN